In this section, we'll cover how to add our blueprint to our level, associate a specific
sequence to the main sequence variable, set up our binding overrides, and finally playtest
ensure everything is functioning correctly.
So back to our project, you'll see that we have the sequence 305 start map open.
If you don't have that open, just go to your content browser, and in the sequence
305 folder, make sure under maps you have the 305 start selected and opened.
Alright, so the first thing that we need to do is to go back to our created blueprint here.
So it should be in our sequence 30500 folder in our BP folder, and we'll just drag and
drop this into our main level, and in this case, I'm going to put it on this platform
in the middle to see this is where the player will start, so that makes it easier
for us to just run and test to make sure this works well.
Alright, so we're going to move this up.
Now again, what matters here, what's important is this collision box here.
So once the player hits the collision box, that's when it's going to trigger what we're doing.
Alright, now the next thing that I need to do is I need to actually add the sequence
we want to play within the kind of general vicinity of this.
I'm going to make it easier and just kind of put it in the middle here.
So we're going to go to our sequence 305, and we're going to look for our SEQ folder,
and we're going to drag and drop this sequence 305 final into here.
We're going to have this here, I'll kind of zoom in a little bit.
Now I'm going to go back and select our BP sequence trigger box, and you'll see here
underneath our default, we have our main sequence variable.
I'm going to select the little eyedropper, and you'll see it say pick actor from scene,
and we're going to pick our sequence.
There we go, we can see the main sequence is now associated.
Now one change we need to make real quick is if you recall from previous classes, we
were using binding overrides within our sequence.
This allows us to take an actor in the level and replace it within the sequence at runtime.
So let's select our sequence, and we're going to scroll down here in the details panel,
and we're looking for our binding overrides.
Go ahead and click the little plus button to add a binding override.
We'll expand this out, and our binding ID, we're actually looking for our SKM bot A,
and then the bound actor is actually going to be this SKM bot runtime within our level,
so we can just select the drop-down and just search for SKM.
There's our SKM bot runtime, and we should be good to go.
All right, at this juncture, our logic should be set up, everything should be configured,
and now we can play test, so I'm going to go ahead and just click play.
See here's our game, we can run, and as soon as we hit this trigger box,
it should trigger our sequence.
We'll let this play for a second, then coming up here, we should now be presented
with our pause, there we go, perfect, that's our little debug sphere,
and now hopefully this will work, if I press the P key, it should unpause,
perfect, our event triggered, keeps going, and you'll notice now if we run around,
because we had that destroy actor, we can't retrigger this.
Perfect, it worked.
The project also includes a blueprint with extra code to display a UMG widget on screen,
then giving two choices for the player that will choose one of two alternate ending sequences
based on the player's selection.
Now as this goes beyond what is covered in this course, we won't be building this code,
however, I wanted to include this for your reference.
Let me just run through a quick overview of the blueprint code to show you how it's
constructed and how it works, so if you want to implement something like this in
your own project, you can.
So back in our project, if I go to my content browser, you'll see under sequence 90500,
there is a maps folder, and if you open the sequence 905 final, you'll see, and this
should pop up, again this is our little section here where the player spawns,
that this is the more enhanced version of the trigger box.
So that's going to be found if we go back to our sequence 305 folder under BP,
the sequence trigger box final.
And just to explain real quick what this does, so with the actor selected in the level,
you'll see that we have our main sequence, and we have two options, option A and option B.
Now if I bring this blueprint back over here real quick, I'm just going to briefly
show what's different from what we had created before.
Now this has been heavily annotated, so it should hopefully be understandable what's
happening here.
But if you notice, here's our event begin play, our pause dispatcher, our pause etc.
So this is all code we've already created.
Our event actor begin overlap, you'll see that we have again triggering our player,
collision, play the sequence, and then creating this custom kind of boolean that
we can use elsewhere.
So after the pause node on our event begin play, kind of construct here, you'll see
that we have this display UMG on screen, and in this case we're going to create a UMG,
which is available here, you can browse to it, it'll open up in the sequence 305
UMG, it's just a custom UMG widget that we've created here, it's over, and all
it is is simply gives us two buttons, option A and option B.
And then we're going to do some things with the user's mouse to allow for input,
you'll see that we create another event to branch, now in this case this could be changed
if you have multiple options, but in this case we have option one, option two, so we're
going to use true and false, and then from there we will play, so here's our option
A variable sequence, here's our option B, and then we'll continue playing, hide
the mouse cursor, and then destroy our actor.
That's really about it, now again you can select this, it is available, you can kind
of preview it, and if you want to, again this is in the sequence 905 final map, if
you hit play, run up to this, you'll see what happens on screen again, it's the same
sequence that plays, but when we pause, we pull up the UMG widget on screen, as the
player you can select option A, option B, and then it will play that sequence based
off of that.